in 2022
say somebody wants to get the feature
and
the video and they want you to be a
prior a primary artist on the record
so they wanted the primary the video the
feature
what's that bag
oh like how much i would charge right
yeah
some [ __ ] off the street let's
say the song is just what it's okay it's
not even it's just whatever it's just
like
say some rich dude's son
like yo
blue face i want you to do the record
you gotta be primary artists on it on
spotify and you gotta do the video
what's that bag
it's not really about the bag like first
i'm gonna i'm gonna control the record
so what if this is established what if
the song is terrible
i'm gonna make it i'm gonna make it
better okay i'm gonna try to do that but
uh like for me to like really take take
it apart and like do it probably i'm
reasonable bro give me like 50. that's
not bad for the primary artist look yeah
and i'm going to promote it i'm going to
promote it like i did
i'm going to promote it like yeah the
ddg record was like yeah like i that's
another thing like
i promote my features too so it's like
that's why it does you know make the
difference in
maybe the regular song and
well i think we've seen like records
like that you've hopped on
go over the top like the outside record
shout out to bobby billions shout out to
dallas
that record i feel like um
are at peanut mode 3 but i feel like
when when you became a part of that
record it kind of really started to take
off in a different way yeah yeah exactly
you know so yeah it took off from like
more mainstream yeah yeah like moe three
was more like his [ __ ] took off more
like like the streets was really filling
up that record when like was that a
record that you you found on your own or
like how did that [ __ ]
so i like doing the remixes i don't know
if you've noticed so i've noticed i got
the that one the outside the moonwalking
the enely chopper remix
i don't know i just like the remixes
because i feel like
i am a difference maker on the song
and that's like the best way for me to
like show you without telling you